(man) the sharks are back
looking for the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
If they hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money.
This business is a cash suck.
(makes sucking sound)
Now welcome to hell.
You just met the devil.
(exhales deeply)
Isn't a cougar typically older?
'cause she looks Younger than
you are.
I'm 35.
(growls)
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I--my point to you is when
you go to the next round...
Phil, you can't do that deal.
You'll be wiped out by the time
the second round hits.
Well,
he's offering $1 million.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-Made,
filthy rich investors.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-Filled city
of manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-Shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-Made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas mavericks.
My name's Ryan Custer.
I'm from trophy club, texas,
and my business is inspired by
my beautiful girlfriend.
I'm 11 years Dusty's junior.
And when I started dating Dusty,
it just clicked.
Getting the taste
of dating an older woman,
I-I noticed
so many more attributes
that she has opposed
to a Younger woman.
She's respectable,
she's playful, sexy.
(Dusty) some of the benefits
of being with a Younger man?
He plays great with my kids.
(Ryan) I am
the ultimate entrepreneur.
I have gone all in.
I have invested three and a half
years of my life.
I've invested every cent
that I've had.
I've liquidated
all my retirement accounts,
my 401(k),
swallowed my pride
and continued to live
with my--My "Roommates"...
Hey, Ryan, time to get up. Dad's
got breakfast cooking. Come on.
My parents,
for the past five years.
Maybe one day I'll be able
to move out.
(both laugh)
You know, I've worked
my Butt off for three years,
developing a product
for what women want,
and the sharks will give me
the opportunity to now get that
in front of all the women
that--That are asking for it.
♪♪
My name is Ryan Custer.
My company is cougar limited.
And I'm seeking $150,000
for 30% equity in my company.
The cougar--
Modern, mm, sexy!
Confident.
Like the woman herself,
the term "Cougar" has become
a pop culture phenomenon.
What started as a cute phrase
has become
a True social movement...
(chuckles)
a recognizable brand
with the type of awareness
that billions of dollars
of persuasive advertising
and marketing could never buy.
Well, I've taken
that cougar term
and applied it to one of
the fastest-Growing industries
in the food
and beverage market.
Introducing...
Cougar energy drink for women--
the industry's first
gender-Specific
functional beverage.
Cougar's infused
with 13 Super fruits
that gives the cougar stronger
hair, skin, and nails.
(growls)
Hormonal balance support...
(speaks indistinctly)
And a list
of other antiaging benefits.
Those elements are combined with
a female-Friendly energy blend
that give the cougar
a long-Lasting energy boost
throughout the day,
with age-Defined support.
It's also a great mixer.
Cougartini?
With the launch of cougar
comes an even more Valuable
lifestyle brand.
I have secured
the cougar trademark,
and it is my vision
to introduce multiple
age-Defying product lines
to capitalize
on This modern cougar movement
that many women
now confidently support.
Isn't a cougar typically older?
'cause she looks Younger
than you are.
Well, she's been drinking
the cougar, the--
(sharks laugh)
Drinking shots
for a while now.
How old are you?
I'm 35.
(mark) 35. Great.
Wow. You look great.
Thank you.
(Robert) Isn't that too young
to be a cougar?
Well, actually, if you look
at the Webster dictionary--
There's an official cougar term?
It's a middle-Aged...
middle-Aged.
Woman that seeks
a companionship
with a-a Younger male.
So what is the age bracket
of--of--of the cougar
you're talking about?
Give me the demo market.
Uh, 30 to 55.
So, Barbara,
you used to be a cougar.
(Robert and mark laugh)
Ryan, you said the word
"Launch."
So the word "Launch," to us,
would mean
that it's not out yet.
Uh, yes, sir, it--It is out.
Okay.
It's about and about.
Um, we have, uh, distribution
in the Dallas-Fort worth area.
Is it selling?
Yes, sir, it is. We've done
about $60,000 worth of sales.
In what period of time?
Uh, in about three years.
(Kevin) Oh.
Oh.
(laughs)
(Barbara) Oh.
I'm not here to waste your time.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Ryan, can--Can our cougar
try it?
Absolutely.
She'll actually take you some.
But I want you to really look
at the labels.
The hot pink--It's
in a male-Dominated market,
so you've got your yellows,
your blues,
and--And--And, uh,
your reds.
So it definitely stands out
to the consumer.
Ryan, how many calories in this?
Zero. Zero calories,
zero sugar.
And what's that chalky taste
I have on my tongue now?
Could be, uh,
maybe the niacin.
Niacin is a, uh, detoxifier,
so it's got kind of
a little chalky taste.
You obviously sacrifice flavor
for effect.
It tastes like chalk, honestly.
Uh-huh.
I hate to say it's True.
I'm out.
Where are you selling them at,
Ryan?
We're trying out
some 7-Elevens.
We've got a smoothie king.
Um, I recently found out that
a, uh, curves in pennsylvania
picked it up from amazon,
So, uh...
so you don't have
a distributor per se.
You're making the calls
yourself.
I don't. Correct.
Isn't the problem
with the strategy is
you've trimmed your market
in two ways?
You said you gotta be a woman
and you gotta be a cougar,
which cuts the market
by really 75%.
You've reduced your market size
down to 25% of the market.
Why is that good?
That's good because this was
a gap in the market,
first of all.
There--There are
no gender-Specific or, um,
a female-Like beverage
that is nonrefrigerated.
It can be tossed
into a woman's purse.
The beverage market is
extremely competitive,
because it turns out
that the distributors
that control this space
get paid very well by
the big brands.
They get paid to crush
cockroaches like you.
I'm out.
Does the average woman
want to buy a cougar thing?
Or is there any element
that the woman's gonna think,
"I don't want to buy a cougar
drink. It makes me seem Old."
Uh, you know, that's a--
that's a great comment.
I'm obviously not a female,
so I can only use statistics
to--to prove a point.
Uh, you've got 7.5 million
viewers for "Cougar town."
You've big names in Hollywood
representing it.
You have, uh, a hundred
social dating web sites, so...
Yeah, but, you know, Ryan,
come on.
Look, here's what's going on.
You pick a name and just
because you can find a name
that has some
social attributes to it
doesn't make it a business.
You know, you've just come out
here and just said,
"look, cougar's popular.
It's a popular term.
"We all understand it.
"So if we could slap 'cougar'
on a product,
then that makes it work."
It doesn't work that way.
I'm out.
(Robert) you haven't sold me
on it.
I don't think women are
gonna flock to this.
I think it's a bit
of a gag gift.
If you had 10 million women
that bought this product
and you start to introduce,
uh, your--Your canned
energy drink
and then cougar-Ade,
which is--
That's a big if, Ryan.
You went from me buying
a gag gift to 10 million women.
Look, the other big issue is
a half a million dollar value
on your company.
I mean, that's ludicrous.
So, Ryan--
Well, the--the--obviously,
consumer brands
are gonna--Is gonna need capital
to bring awareness to it.
That's--That's a fact.
You're--You're not--
but I'm standing here
to say, hey,
those--Those clothing.
I designed those myself.
I made 'em in house myself.
Everything that you see.
I'm out.
Appreciate it. This, uh,
this presentation, um,
I hope, uh, impressed y'all,
and...
apparently not.
Thank you for your time.
(mark) Good luck.
Good luck, Ryan.
It definitely hurts.
Uh, am I gonna quit? No.
I'll go back home,
take a breather,
and go sell my energy shots.
I'm not giving up.
Cougar for life.
♪♪
Next up is Gary Gagnon
with a line of sneakers that is
fashionable and responsible.
Hello, sharks.
Nice to meet you.
Glad to be here.
My name is Gary Gagnon.
I'm the founder and creator
of remyxx.
I'm asking for $50,000
for 10% of my company.
What I have for you here today
is more than
just a great product.
It's an innovation.
It's a sneaker
with a purpose.
As you can see,
I have cool, casual sneakers
in strong colors,
with clever designs,
for mass market appeal.
But I'd have to be crazy...
to think I'm gonna enter
the footwear industry...
(laughs)
Yep.
To go up against
these big sneaker giants.
You see,
that's where I am crazy--
Crazy with a kick
that I know only remyxx
can deliver.
What's special here is that
remyxx is wholly recyclable.
That means all parts together
can go back into
the recycling system,
not the trash,
for zero landfill impact.
Sharks, I'm asking you to be
a pioneer.
I'm asking you to join me
on the ground floor
to help make a change
in the way we think about
sneakers and green living.
Gary, you got any sales?
My sales.
My sales--I would say...
(chuckles)
Are exactly where they would be
for any company
as new as remyxx.
So they're zero.
My sales are zero.
Mm. Okay.
I can explain.
Yeah, why don't you?
This two years' worth of work
is only now three weeks old.
Gary, is your concept
that you're gonna set up
retail stores?
Is your concept
that you're gonna sell
the component of how to do this
the existing shoe manufacturers?
What's the game plan?
I mean, you're brand-New,
you don't have any stores.
What's the plan?
G-Game plan is wholesale,
uh, so it's gonna go into
your--your big box stores,
that just like everybody else,
they'll be right next
to the other big guys.
I'm different. I'm special. They
don't have this. Like I said--
May I see that?
Oh, absolutely. Please.
(daymond) why don't you
send out a tray of sneakers
so we can see the product?
Please.
No, give me a pretty color,
like the green or the pink.
Got that one just for you.
Um, and I do have a size 10
that fits you, I believe, sir.
Yeah, thank you.
Oh, these are very cool.
Here's some nice purple ones.
Is the logo part
of your branding?
Thank you, sir.
'cause I like--
I love the logo.
I do, too. (laughs)
I can wear mine.
Um, so the 5 is
actually a symbol
of the type of materials used.
It's--That's a--
that's a universal symbol.
The recycle symbol is
common domain.
Gary, am I allowed to--
'cause This is gonna be
a bit of a problem--
I know in my house,
my kids are religious
about putting the right stuff
in the recycle bin.
Right.
If I put these shoes
in my recycle bin,
will the garbage folks
pick them up?
So technically,
these can go curbside.
The processors
that receive it--
they don't know
what a remyxx sneaker is yet.
Right.
So what I've offered here--
mail it back to me.
I can guarantee
it gets recycled.
I can guarantee it goes into
a new pair of sneakers.
Okay. That's clever.
'cause my kids would like that.
They'd like the idea of putting
them in, mailing them somewhere,
knowing they're gonna get
recycled.
Right.
How much have you invested
in this yourself?
Um, $30,000.
And do you have any other
partners or do you own 100%?
That's it.
It's me and my family.
I have two boys
that are 9 and 7--
All over remyxx
with me every day.
Why do you want to do this?
Because you want to be
in fashion...
I-I--
Or you want to do--
Have a green--
You want to contribute?
So first I need to sell
some sneakers.
I can't help the world
or the--the remyxx effort
that I call it
until we--We get some fashion
out there.
What are you gonna do
with the $50,000,
and what's the next step?
Where I'm leading to is for you
to get out of the gate,
you're gonna need way more
than $50,000.
I'm ready. Um...
and you have
maybe 20 patterns there,
I think, to my eye, right?
Uh, yeah, I have 26.
Times six sizes each,
it's 120 different sneakers.
(Robert) Wow.
That's a lot of money--
Your point.
I'm just--
Yeah, let him answer.
Um, that's the $50,000,
for the molds.
So it's just--It's for the mold
and inventory
to get the first order sold.
And then when that goes--
No, no, no, no.
Gary, come on.
You're gonna need Well more--
I mean, daymond can talk
to this--
You're gonna need more than
$50,000 to build the molds
and create the inventory.
You're not even gonna--You're
not even gonna get the money
until after you deliver it,
it's sold through,
and then they give you the--
Basically your money back,
so how can you get
the molds prior?
The second I get an order,
great.
200 pairs, 3,000 pairs,
whatever it is--
I will make the sizes based
on that order I get.
Right.
So that $50,000
will go a long way.
Gary, is there anything
about this process
that would be proprietary
and patentable that we could--
If was your partner...
Mm-hmm.
Take to one of
the giant shoe manufacturers
that has a brand
that's known globally?
'cause one of the things
that bothers me the most
about this business is,
any one of the giant four
can do this in two seconds.
I believe there is
several patents--
Just how much you spend
on which one to protect--
the construction of the shoe.
These are not good answers.
(Robert) It's a brand play.
You gotta create the market.
(mark) He gave you
an honest answer.
There's nothing unique
that you can license
to one
of the big shoe companies.
That--That's the answer.
You know, if you did
something bad on earth
and went to hell,
this is the business
you'd have to work in.
Competing with the biggest guys
all around the world.
Why did you--
I'd have to be crazy to meet
with--Go against them.
But you--Gary, why?
What's the reason?
It's unique, it's different,
it's a distinction all its own,
it hasn't been done.
I'm first. Let's go.
I got a trademark name.
You should go for it, Gary,
but you got a bigger problem.
(Kevin) Yeah.
This business is
a cash suck, right?
(makes sucking sound)
(Kevin) right.
That's all the cash.
You didn't ask for enough.
You know, you may be crazy,
but you weren't crazy enough
to ask,
because even when you build
your molds specific to order,
right, then you gotta do
the inventory.
And if you get a second order,
you gotta get even more molds
and more inventory.
No, I don't need the molds.
Once the molds are done,
they're done.
Gary, you're missing the point.
You're missing the point.
You're gonna need millions
of dollars to build inventory.
These people don't pay on time.
Daymond, what's the average time
a large retailer is
gonna pay you for an order?
It's--It's 90 days Max.
It's gonna be 90 days,
But first of all,
they're gonna test it,
number one,
second of all, after one month
on the shelves,
they reduce it by, I think,
10% each week
that it stays on the shelf.
So before you know it--
before you know it...
it really is hell, isn't it?
You gotta there and start out
working in the stockroom.
So, Gary, that's my problem.
If you're successful,
you could go bankrupt.
I'm out.
Gary, where do you live
in the country?
I live in north Carolina.
Okay, it gets cold there
in february.
You know what I'm thinking?
Take these shoes, burn 'em.
Stay warm.
You can't burn 'em.
They'll get recycled before they
get burned, But thank you.
Please, I implore you,
let me burn those.
Please. I'm out.
Gary, you're gonna get
that first order.
You'll make the molds.
Then you're gonna have to
invest in inventory,
and you know what? The minute
they see that inventory
on a shelf somewhere, someone
else is gonna place an order,
and then you're screwed.
Because you haven't been able
to see far enough out
and to plan for it
and to ask for enough money,
that's why I'm out.
Gary, I just don't buy in
to a unique sales pitch
that recyclable sneakers are
a product people want.
There's 300 million shoes
thrown away a year.
Yes, and I don't think--
The sustainability market
is huge.
Yes, and I don't think
this is unique enough. I'm out.
Sorry to hear that.
(Robert) So four people are out.
You've got--You've got
the fashion guru,
fubu, Mr. Billion dollar
Fashion guy left.
Do your best sales pitch.
You've been there, daymond.
You've--You know
what it's like.
The difference for me is
I'm--I'm just--just starting,
just like--Same--Same train
of action that you might've had.
Do you own the name?
Remyxx is trademarked, yes.
You own the--and you do own
the Web site as well?
I have remyxx my sneakers--
Daymond, are these the shoes
from hell?
I like this recycle idea.
Unfortunately,
the offer I would have
to give you,
you really would have to
be crazy.
He said he was.
♪♪
Four sharks are out,
and daymond is Gary's
last chance to make a deal.
The offer I would have
to give you,
you really would
have to be crazy.
He said he was.
For $50,000,
I would have to have
80% of the company.
(Robert) Whoa.
(Kevin) Pfft.
Now welcome to hell.
Can I--
You just met the devil.
No, daymond is not the devil.
Daymond's a smart businessman.
Obviously, to be a partner with
you would be a dream come True.
I--
what are you gonna do?
To come back to you and say
can we go 50/50 for $100,000?
Just so I don't have to
come back to you again
for the next level
of inventory.
You will not have to come back
to me for the inventory at all.
I will either license it out,
put it into my own products,
or bankroll
whatever we're doing there,
so you won't need
any more money.
Awesome
and I love to hear that.
The last appeal--I don't--
I don't want to--
I'm not trying to haggle--
I understand. You have to
understand what's going on.
I have a family.
(exhales deeply)
So my two boys--
I look at this
as I'm the first generation
of remyxx.
I'd like there to be
a second generation of remyxx.
That my boys are
very well aware of.
So I still ask you for 50/50.
The purpose of you asking
for 50/50
is for a second generation
of remyxx. Correct?
Well, what I'm gonna teach you
in this business
you're gonna pass on
to your boys
and you're gonna also have
the money--
I'm telling you now--And I hate
to kill people's dreams,
But the direction
you're heading,
you're gonna spend everything
that you ever even
held Aside for them.
(sighs deeply)
I'm a family man.
I know.
I'm buying more into you
than anything else.
You will teach your boys
how to be what you are now
and what I am now.
Gary, what are you gonna do?
Make a decision.
I-I obviously, I do trust you,
and that'd be a dream come True.
Does it ever come back to you,
say "Gary, I need more percent"?
no.
No.
(Robert) 50 grand for 80%.
Mark, will you pair of, uh...
done.
Remyxx courtside?
Done. Yeah, I like 'em.
We have a deal.
Good job, Gary.
I just--I just created
another job for myself.
All right?
(mark) You hired him.
He paid--
Thank you, daymond.
Thank you.
How many people...
I'm not gonna let you down.
Get paid to hire daymond?
Right?
I'm gonna believe in you.
Thank you, sir.
(Robert) Nice job.
It's a good deal, Gary.
Congratulations.
Thank you for all your support.
You, too, Kevin.
(Robert) Congratulations.
Thanks for the shoes.
Good luck to you.
And I wear a size 12.
(voice breaking) Boys, we've
talked about remyxx many times.
It's happenin'.
we got daymond. We got you.
Thank you for--
boys, for your support.
Thank you.
♪♪
Earlier in this season,
we watched
alashe Nelson make a deal with
daymond John and mark Cuban
for his company ez vip,
a web site where you can buy
V.I.P. Treatment
at nightclubs
and special events.
I'll sweeten it a little bit.
I will bring an a-list artist
to it.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪
So today I'm in miami,
where al is
joining me
for an important lunch meeting,
and I have a surprise that is
gonna blow his mind.
Good flight coming in?
What's happening?
Yeah, everything was good.
When we did the deal...
Mm-hmm.
I said I was gonna bring
an a-List artist...
Mm-hmm.
And I am a man of my word.
Where you going with this, man?
Where you going with this?
Introducing...
Armando, a.K.A. Mr. Worldwide,
a.K.A. Pitbull.
No way!
Pitbull,
the international superstar,
whose songs have topped
the "billboard" Charts
has agreed to be the face
of ez vip.
When daymond, you know, brought
the opportunity to the table,
I said I definitely want to be
involved, one way or another.
With his endorsement, ez vip
will be the go-To web site
for everything nightlife.
Something that can be global...
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
And something that can give
those that never had V.I.P.
Ez vip.
Exactly. Exactly.
When pitbull walked up,
I was like, oh, my God.
That's Mr. Worldwide.
That's pitbull.
And for him to be part of my
company, it's great, you know?
You know, pit's
a very shrewd businessman.
Uh-huh.
He cannot and will not align
himself with many brands.
He's very decisive.
But he also thought
of many other ways
to expand ez vip.
Great.
You gotta buckle up,
get ready for the ride.
I'm excited.
It makes me feel great to help
al and his business,
and in the end, we're all gonna
have a lot of fun...
(alashe) right.
And make a lot of money.
To ez vip, my friends.
Success.
Ez vip.
♪♪
Next into the tank are
Frank campitelli
and debrae barensfeld
with a fitness product
they believe is better
than all the rest.
Hi. I'm Frank campitelli.
Hi, I'm debrae barensfeld.
We are personal trainers
from Medina, ohio.
We are seeking $250,000
for 10% equity
in nitroforce industries,
which is home of the lightest,
strongest, safest,
fastest, most versatile,
most affordable home gym
on the planet--
The nitroforce titan 1000.
We've come up with
over a hundred exercises,
but there's no limit to what
the imagination can make up,
and right now, we just
want to show you a few.
Frank is doing
a shoulder press,
and he's gonna turn around
and be in the perfect position
for a squat.
We actually have
a leg press attachment
which we have as an upsell.
And now we're just gonna
remove the bench very quickly
with just one pull pin.
And...
This is our nitro shock.
This weighs 2 pounds,
offers 250 pounds of resistance.
Our gas shocks have no weight.
It's massless.
That's where we get
our benefit.
What I'm gonna do right now is
put this
in a pulling position...
(Click)
And we can do
a couple exercises.
You would do barbell style
from the bottom.
This is an upright row.
And we're gonna do a shrug.
My personal favorite is
the dead lift.
We like to say, tighten
your Butt, tighten your gut,
titan 1000.
(Frank chuckles)
right now, we're gonna change
the machine
into a pull-Down mode
and attach this--The, uh, uh,
c-Cable assembly really quick.
Really quick. There we go.
Are you gonna show Us
all 100 exercises?
No.
No, this is our last one
that we're gonna show you.
Um, with one arm,
you can grab it.
And this is very exciting.
It's a bench punch.
And we believe that the M.M.A.
Would be extremely interested in
that. They can't do anything--
That was a 30-Pound punch
and that was fast.
Is this your prototype that
we're looking at, right here?
This is actually
a manufactured piece.
We have, uh, about 90 of them
in a warehouse right now.
So you don't have any sales yet?
Well, we didn't really try.
We've sold 26 just to, uh,
clients. We're per--
At what price?
Uh, the price is $1,299.
$1,300?
Yes.
So what's your--
That was--That was
with free shipping.
What's your cost to build?
Our cost was $259.
You valued your business
at 2 and a 1/2 million dollars.
You have no sales.
No. We--
Well--Go ahead.
We've had sales,
but we've done no marketing.
We did all our testing.
Uh, there were same things
that we had to change
that I was--I felt that were--
You know,
from the manufacturing,
weren't gonna make it, so--
Where's the part where
it's worth $2 1/2 million?
Um, the intellectual property.
And, Frank,
you said you had sales?
Well, yes.
How many?
20.
26.
Because you're trainers, you're
selling the to your clients.
Right.
How much have you invested
in total?
Total--Uh, money-Wise,
about $200,000
between the two of us.
But this is
eight years going.
What's your vision with this?
Is this something you're gonna
sell direct to consumers?
(both) Yes.
So as--As you know, 98%
of all equipment sold
into that market
is never used more than once.
Right.
That's because the equipment
usually isn't good enough
for the user.
No, be--It's because most people
are pretty lazy
and don't want
to put the effort in.
Actually, most of our--
You know, your industry was--
your industry was born
with Suzanne Somers
and the thigh master.
And ever since then,
the model's never changed.
It takes a tremendous amount
of capital
to do a massive...
that's right.
Launch, and, you know,
at the end of the day,
you don't know until you've
spent half a million bucks
if you're gonna make it or not.
I'm out.
Who do you see
as your primary competition?
Every device out there.
One of the things
that this thing can do
that those other products
that have done a billion dollars
can't do is penetrate
the intermediate
and professional expert who are
already working out.
But, Frank, to sell
a lot of this equipment,
it's not guys like you
or guys that work out,
it's guys like O'Leary.
(Barbara laughs)
You--You need guys
that never go to the gym.
I really don't understand
why This is different from
everything else out there.
Resistance. Our gas shocks.
Weights will cause damage.
They also hurt your tendons
and your joints.
On this,
you cannot hurt yourself.
You don't get those injuries.
See, that's a tough sale.
It's gonna cost you $2 million
to educate people
just to even
start thinking that.
I'm out.
You guys, the real issue is
you can't come
into the shark tank
looking for
a $2.5 million Valuation
without having a proven sales
distribution model,
and for that reason, I'm out.
Every time my husband goes
on a business trip,
I get three or four handymen
to help me throw out
his latest acquisitions
and sports equipment.
So I couldn't think
of anyone less likely
to buy in to your product.
I'm out.
So I was thinking of my wife.
Would my wife buy this?
I-I think she would find it
a little intimidating.
It's too industrial.
It's too expensive.
It's too difficult.
It takes up too much space.
Why are--
and that's too many toos.
Too many toos.
I'm out.
Uh, and you're out.
Can we just put
a little statistic out there?
In the history
of direct-Response television,
there's been 11 products
do a billion dollars.
Four of them are home gyms.
This will be the next one.
I don't think this is the one.
Frank, debrae, thanks.
We wish you the best, guys.
(mouths word)
Barbara,
look how big that is.
Oh, my God.
That's bigger than
your entire apartment.
I would kill bill
if he brought that home.
If they want to keep their money
and be skeptics, that's fine.
It doesn't deter me one bit.
Uh...
we're just gonna keep going.
We're not gonna give up.
We've got a nitroforce
in our living room,
and we're gonna get a nitroforce
in Everybody's living room.
♪♪
Next up is Phil Dumas
with an update to a product
that hasn't been changed
in a thousand years.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Phil Dumas
and my company is
unikey technologies.
I'm looking
for a $500,000 investment
for a 33% equity stake.
My passion is access control.
I know that sounds weird,
but it really is.
Now the interesting thing
about this market to me is
is that the key really has not
evolved in over 1,100 years.
That's a long time.
But my product, unikey,
is the revolution of the key.
I'm gonna incorporate your key
into your mobile phone.
And now, you can take
this big old bulky keychain
and get rid of it.
It's that simple.
(keys thud)
Let me show you how it works.
As long as I'm in range
of the lock,
I can control it.
(whirs)
Oh.
Now I simply walk out of range,
and, mark,
if you could do me a favor
and just hang on
to my phone/key for me.
You can see just a regular user
has no control over the lock.
They can only lock it. They
cannot unlock the lock again.
So if somebody leaves,
they can lock the lock for you.
Cool.
(Barbara) Mm.
Now if I come back into range,
you'll see
I gain access again.
This is me. Walking up,
I gain access to my lock.
It's that simple.
Now another unique thing
about unikey is
is by having the key
on your phone,
we can send and receive keys
to and from other users
on a onetime extended
and permanent use basis.
So if you have a friend
come in to town
and gets home before you,
you can send him a onetime key.
If you have a maid service that
comes over every wednesday
from 2:00 to 3:00 p.M.,
their key can work
for just that period of time
so you can rest assured
they can't get into your home
at any other time.
And then obviously,
you can send a permanent key
to your spouse and your kids.
But more importantly, at any
time, you can delete these keys.
It's that simple.
So with your help,
your capital, and experience,
we can change
the access control market.
Thank you very much for your
time. Are there any questions?
(Robert) Phil, very cool.
Is it a retrofit
to existing keys,
or do I have to buy
a brand-New lock,
brand-New handle,
brand-New everything?
Great question.
Our technology is two bolts out,
two bolts in with a new lock.
On that lock, what is yours?
New lock.
You have to buy a new lock?
Yes, we have the technology
that goes into the lock.
I'm actually working With
black & Decker right now.
Can I use the regular original
key on that lock if I want?
Yes. So if your phone dies
or you don't have it with you,
we recommend you keep
a key laying around
or one of your neighbors.
You can just walk up
and use a standard key.
Is this patented?
We have an all-Inclusive
provisional patent filed,
which part of the equity,
uh, money that I'm raising
is gonna use to take that
into a nonprovisional status.
Is your strategy to license this
technology to a manufacturer
that distributes locks?
Yes, so I'm working
with black & Decker
on a licensing structure
of my technology,
their lock, their sales,
their marketing.
So what's the next step
With black & Decker?
I'm gonna drop This off
tomorrow,
and they're presenting it
at their closed door
Executive Meeting next week.
Phil, I have a basic question--
What do you sell it for?
The goal is to get it to market
at $149 to $199.
And that's ultimately up
to black & Decker,
how they decide to price it.
What about someone who just
wants to use a key?
What do they pay
for a similar lock?
$30.
So the difference is $100.
Should I be worried
that it's such a huge premium
to an ordinary lock
in this economy?
Absolutely not. People are
buying technologies.
So, Phil, I'm very interested.
I'm thinking This is fantastic.
Thank you.
Why not go to black & Decker,
raise the money from them
for a 1-Year exclusive
in the market?
They don't fund
the development.
They're happy to pay
a royalty agreement.
Now they're not my only pony.
Anything with a key, anything
with a password, we can go to.
We just need to further develop
the technology.
And they're a customer that
really wants this technology.
And if they don't--
I'll be honest with you--
We can take this
to market ourselves
and do very well
on the internet.
In your dealings
with black & Decker,
what do you assume
the royalty to be?
Uh, I want to go for about
7 1/2% of gross sales.
You've asked for $500,000
for a third of the business,
so you're telling me it's worth
one and a half million total.
Post-Money, yes.
How did you come up
with that value?
Pre-Money, $1 million is
very reasonable
for a tech company
with technology like this.
I think mark
can attest to that.
It's not outrageous.
Post-Money--$1.5 million.
How much more money are
you gonna need
to get the first one sold?
I-I really need $1.1 million
to hit profitability.
Now the $500,000 is
I'm calling round "a,"
and there's
an extra $600,000 tranche--
Okay, you've--You got
to this point--
Well, Phil, let's be clear.
That doesn't get you
to profitability.
That simply gets you
to end of proof of concept.
No, the $500,000 does.
Right.
The extra $600,000
gets us to profitability.
So how are you gonna use
that $500,000?
Okay. The first $500,000 is
patent protection.
Then I've got engineering.
So that's a couple hundred
thousand dollars.
Um, we've got equipment
that we need.
We need to buy a bluetooth
full development Stack.
Those cost a minimum
of 50 grand.
$500,000--That is
the absolute minimum
I can take it
from point "a" to point "B."
And there's a little bit
of cushion in there,
but to be honest,
I'd like a little bit more.
But $500,000 is
a lot of money.
Absolutely. But for a product
like this--
Now don't think--'cause, you
know, a lot of people think
'cause you're sitting up here
with us that that's easy.
That's a lot of money.
No, I don't think
it's easy at all.
I haven't raised it yet.
(chuckles)
So agree with me on this.
Yeah.
The entire value of this concept
is hinging on a deal
with black & Decker.
Absolutely not.
Okay, that's one channel.
Anything in access control
we can go into.
I'm not putting all my eggs
in that one basket,
but it's a great opportunity,
and they're
extremely interested.
So my only Risk is
put some money in, develop it,
make sure it works?
I'm gonna make sure
you get your money back
if I have to sell 'em
all by myself.
How?
How are you gonna assure us
we're gonna get our money back?
He's a hustler.
I'm gonna make it happen.
I come from
the private equity field.
I'm actually--I have my degree
in Electrical engineering
from the university
of central Florida. Go, knights.
Okay, I come from
the private equity field.
Literally,
in the private equity firm,
my title was V.P. Of m.I.H.
I made it happen.
Oh, I love that.
I like it right there.
All right, look,
I'm in great pain right now.
Let me explain why. Okay?
You're very credible,
and I love your story about
making it happen
and the fact you come
from the private equity world--
That's all plus.
On the negative side,
the housing market is
a disaster.
Your product costs
Three times as much
as the solution that goes
in every door today.
We've got a lot
of development risk,
and if black & Decker passes,
we have to market this
ourselves.
So there's a lot of angst.
I've got--
There's not a lot
of development risk.
Everything I have planned out,
we know what we're gonna do.
But hear me out--
We're gonna hit bumps
in the road.
We're gonna solve
those problems.
The hew home Market really
doesn't buy keypad locks.
People put those on afterwards.
So we're not directly linked
to the new home market.
But there's many different types
of deals in life.
This is one where I love
the story, but I feel the risk.
But I want a piece of it,
so here's what I'm gonna do.
I'll put $100,000 down.
You still have to raise $400,000
from other sharks.
But I want the end deal to be
for 50% of the company.
So 10%. You give him
100 grand for 10%.
Precisely.
Thank you very much.
You have to raise
the other $400,000 from us.
Thank you for your offer.
Thank you.
So at least you got $100,000
from the bank of tank right now.
It's better than
most people get,
and it starts the juices
flowing, my friend.
Okay. It's an offer.
Thank you.
Phil, I love the fact
that you love something
as Boring as locks.
(laughs)
I-I've been in internet security
for 28 years,
and I love it.
Nobody understands it.
It's Boring, yeah.
But I love it. It's Boring
to everyone else except to me.
Yeah.
Here's what I'll do.
I'll give you $1 million
for 75% of it.
You keep 25%,
but it's contingent
on Getting black & Decker in.
♪♪
Phil has a partial offer on
the table from Kevin O'Leary,
But Robert has just raised
the stakes.
Here's what I'll do.
I'll give you $1 million
for 75% of it,
you keep 25%,
but it's contingent
on Getting black & Decker in.
Let me tell you why
I need black & Decker.
I need 'em, too.
Proof of concept.
But it's not
our only customer.
I need them to prove the market.
Absolutely, but...
so $1 million.
But please understand--
It's not our only customer.
Thank you very much.
No, no, no. Phil, did I say
it's our only market?
Okay. All right.
I'm saying We need somebody
to step up, prove the market
so we can go sell it
to other people.
And I'm very confident.
$1 million. 75%.
You keep 25%.
That's a lot of equity.
Are they gonna ask
for exclusivity?
Uh, in the residential lock
market, let's be reasonable.
What other market is there?
That's the largest market
there is.
We can negotiate that.
Computer access, uh...
Yeah, But the residential
lock market is what, 80%--
Bicycle locks.
So who cares? He offered you
$100,000 for 10%.
I mean, it's--
You gotta get $500,000.
Fair point.
But thank you and thank you.
Actually, mine's far less
diluted than his.
It is.
You just--
but it's still a lot of equity.
Phil. Phil, I have an offer,
all right?
Okay.
Because for whatever reason,
since you presented this,
I'm gonna be annoyed every time
I pull out my key from now on.
But I'm gonna give you
half of the $500,000
for 25% of the business
if you get mark cuban
to buy the other 25%.
(laughs)
Thank you for your offer.
Why don't you see
what mark has to say?
I'm waiting.
So am I.
(Barbara laughs)
Phil, two words--
Great presentation.
Thank you.
Um, I want to be
in this tech space really bad,
but I have some exit wounds
from other deals I've done.
I have a partnership with great
product development people.
If we use my people--and I have
a deal with hsn--
We try to go right on there.
Whoa. Are--Are you ready
with an offer?
Yeah. 40%,
half a million dollars.
And then there was one.
(chuckles)
Okay, I'll make it easy.
Thank you.
I get it, so here's
what I want to do.
And I'm gonna preface This
by saying
when I make my offer,
I also understand
that you're gonna have to
raise another $600,000.
So what I'm gonna do is--
Barbara, I love you, but--
don't give me the "But."
It's not a good sign.
This isn't your--
This isn't your wheelhouse.
But Kevin's strength
is in beating people
up over the numbers.
And I like that about Kevin.
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful.
(laughs)
So, Phil,
what I'm willing to do is
I'm gonna take up Kevin
on his contribution,
and I'll provide $400,000.
So in aggregate,
it's $500,000,
but assuming Kevin's willing
to go along with this...
I'm in.
We want 45% of the company.
I came in here wanting to do
a deal with you, mark.
I think this is
right up your alley.
Would you two consider 40%?
I'll split the difference
at 42 1/2%.
(Robert) Phil, hang on a sec.
Hang on a sec.
Key thing
in what Mr. Cuban said.
You're gonna have to raise
more money.
In his deal and O'Leary's deal,
you're already diluted.
You've already gone down to 55%.
What do you think's gonna happen
in the next round?
And they're pegging the value
of this business today
at about a million bucks.
I'm giving you
a higher enterprise value
right off the bat,
more cash, twice the money,
and you're getting 25%.
All right, would you be willing
to come down on your equity?
I mean, you're at 75% equity.
That's a massive number.
I understand.
I-I-I avoid two rounds almost.
Look, you realize my point--
My point to you is when
you go to the next round--
Phil, you can't do that deal.
You'll be wiped out by the time
the second round hits.
Well,
he's offering $1 million.
Yeah, but the point is you
may need more than $1 million.
We don't know
what's gonna happen.
Phil, look, you know from
your background in tech,
it's not about 2%, 5%, right?
It's about the assistance you're
going to get
and the opportunity
in front of you.
I completely understand.
Right. So that's where it is.
And giving up more equity--
That's what you're fighting
for, the equity, right?
Look, 40%, we have a deal.
Then how are you gonna protect
me in the next round?
40% and I'll give you
two seats on the board
so you have control over
the board of directors.
So it's a balance of power.
What do you think, kev?
That's a fair guy.
With two seats.
You have two directors now?
No, I'm the only
board director.
So you guys have control
of the board,
I have control of the stock.
It's a balance of power.
Kevin?
I'm in.
I'm in as well.
You have a deal.
Done and done.
That's how we roll.
He took the right deal.
(Kevin) Very impressive.
It's the wrong deal.
It's the right deal.
Do not negotiate black & Decker
without me there.
Yeah.
That's what he's good at.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate your offer.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
(Barbara) Nice job here, today.
I really appreciate
your offer as well.
I like that.
It was a great deal for you.
What did he call himself?
A problem solver.
And he had a problem
right in front of me
and he came up
with a solution like that.
But, mark, I am annoyed.
You couldn't have gotten rid
of me in a more gracious manner?
Barbara, you ride in on a Broom,
you gotta leave on a Broom.
You pick this guy--Oh, god.
It was unbelievable to get
an offer from all the sharks
and get them fighting,
but I feel like I got the best.
I've got the two billionaires
backing me.